the city of dubrovnik on croatia's
adriatic coast is
often called the jewel of the
mediterranean it's famous for its
medieval buildings and beautiful narrow
alleyways
the pozod restaurant is situated right
at the edge of the historic district
a favorite of tourists and locals alike
it was opened by mario schabel
six years ago since then it's turned
into one of the city's top eateries
having a restaurant is more more than
job for me
that's a life you need to live with this
restaurant if you
that's like a wife this is my second
wife
fish and seafood are typical of
dubrovnik's cuisine
and the dalmatian region as a whole
local fishermen deliver their catch to
the restaurant each morning
one of its specialties is mussels
bizarra a regional dish made of
shellfish
the muscles what we get in our
restaurant is coming
from the dominican coast and it's so
fresh and it's
most important thing the people do that
just for the living and
the delivery us over here every morning
to get
fresh things in our restaurant
but there's more to mussels bizarro
mario heads to the market in dubrovnik's
historic district
which is open every weekday
is one of croatia's most important
agricultural regions
so there's a rich selection
mario buys locally grown vegetables and
herbs for his restaurant
they'll also go into the sauce for his
muscles bazara
this is the best place in the brony in
an old town because
you can find the fresh ingredients for
the restaurant and a buy on the same
place
they're coming all from the jupa that's
the near of the bronic
after shopping it's time to return to
the restaurant chef rajon knezich is
cooking today
and the ingredients are ready to go in
addition to mussels
there's also tomatoes onions garlic
parsley
olive oil and white wine
first the vegetables are chopped to
shorten the cooking time
while still retaining much of the flavor
and after that's ready it's time to
prepare the mussels
i put them in a pan with some hot olive
oil you don't need to add water
the mussels already have sea water in
them
after a few minutes on high heat the
shells open
that's a sign that the mussels are ready
now it's time to saute onions and garlic
for the sauce
next add tomatoes and parsley
finally the mussels are added to the
sauce and it's all quenched with white
wine
we're using a dry white wine it boils
very briefly
so the alcohol evaporates but the flavor
remains
now they're ready for serving once
considered a humble dish
mussel's bizarre is a relative newcomer
on the menus at finer restaurants
the people probably before 100 or 200
years
eat the muscles buzara because they
don't have enough
nice white fish and probably nice
quality of
meat and they are preparing probably the
buzara
for the for the lunch for a huge family
and they are probably use more bread
than than mussels
nowadays mussels bizarra are considered
a delicacy
but they're still served with bread and
they're supposedly best washed down with
a dry
white wine a local one of course